look at this little guy this is the
Google home a smart speaker that sits on
your nightstand or your coffee table
just waiting for you to chat with it
inside is the Google assistant which is
this voice based platform that you can
talk to about almost anything it's
really a google's version of the amazon
echo and you can do sort of the same
stuff with it okay google set a timer
for 20 minutes okay 20 minutes and we
were starting now okay Google
add pancakes butter and maple syrup to
my shopping list okay I've added
pancakes butter and maple syrup to your
shopping list okay Google what's the
weather tomorrow tomorrow in San
Francisco it'll be sunny with a
forecasted high of 65 and a low of 52 so
Google has all these ideas about how
Google home can be more personal and it
can be involved with your life it knows
your calendar and what traffic is going
to be like before your next meeting but
all the fun stuff is really sort of
hidden inside the Google home there's
all kinds of stuff that you can say and
do that it's just a little bit out there
for instance
okay Google I'm feeling lucky you said
the magic words welcome to game show
mode my friend
okay Google when's your birthday I try
to live every day like it's my birthday
I get more cake that way okay Google
what am I thinking you're thinking it's
my Google assistant dancers what I'm
thinking I'm going to freak out
okay Google up up down down left right
left right BA plus 30 extra lives
okay Google who let the dogs out I wish
I could tell you but that song never did
reveal whoo-whoo-whoo-whoo-whoo
okay Google make me a sandwich you're a
sandwich oh and there's one more that
might come in handy just in case
something goes wrong okay Google
you I'm sorry you feel that way if you'd
like to report a problem you can send
feedback hey Danny
so in general the echo and the Google
home are very similar products you'll
use them for music and for setting
timers and for getting recipes and for
checking the weather and maybe for
finding out if there's traffic on your
way to work tomorrow
they're great things to have in your
house if you have an echo you probably
don't need a home but if you don't
already have a speaker in your home you
can yell at all day for 129 dollars the
home is a pretty great one
okay Google will you be my friend
no question about it okay Google when am
i the present of course TARDIS
functionality is still undergoing
development sorry